I want to see a little bit I felt like
they still held more a v so to me looks
like they need more time for the for the
end so like toward the end of the year
did they are you sure man they show they
showed up they showed a lot of I just me
I wanted I wanted more matter of fact I
take it back the stream was bugging in
the beginning when it was showing all
the combat so I couldn't see all that
stuff that y'all saw so I was like damn
I get a chance to see that CU I was
looking at yeah it was that was the part
I wanted to see the most so I rewatch it
yeah so are are we live yeah oh we live
now okay okay hey guys what's hey
guys pick up 52 Pickup reaction games
leas so what do we think you know about
about the show like I was saying I don't
know how much people heard but uh yeah I
I'm Square being there is my biggest
excitement I love that stuff uh we were
talking about AOW to AOW also is I mean
I come from a PC background obsidian has
always been slaying obsidian is the man
um I'm ready for a vow so much I'm ready
to heat that up I would say hellblade is
on the bottom my list which is how good
this whole thing was cuz hellblade don't
get me wrong don't get me wrong
hellblade looks phenomenal like that's
the hashtag just one right Cog or is it
not tell because it's a sequel but we
don't care we don't care we don't care
continue forget that stuff forget about
all that talk about the game talk about
the game uh yeah no no uh it's
definitely at the bottom of my list but
AOW to me is on the top and Indiana
Jones right next to it man Indiana Jones
kind of they blew me away I'm so
impressed I thought they were going to
go more stylized I thought they were
going to do wolfen Steines kind of thing
but no man they they went all out on
that I'm I'm super impressed
I I'm very excited um what else am I
trying to digest here everything looks
so good I love the whip attacks the whip
attacks guys the whip attacks did you
see that when they use that as a
distraction disarm a disarm a
distraction they they grabbed the
person's gun they swept the person they
dragged people I mean the fist to fist
combat looks awesome it's super gritty
it's super Indie right it's super
Indiana um I'm super excited for it um a
vow one last thing that I'm G to say for
a vow rapid fire is that uh these guys
don't really act I I know we say it a
lot but these guys rarely Miss and um
they're the kings of RPGs on on computer
right a PC they're kings of RPGs and
that's a rpga a RPG like it's really
looking Stellar so I can't wait to do
that they showed the choices they showed
the com you know I love it good it look
good shout to J rose5 Super Chat plus
Call of Duty golf War Rome is burning
shout out iron low podcast J Rose here
salute salute good to see you good to
see you tell the truth Shan the devil J
rose stand up put your hands up go oh
yeah and it looks like we're getting
more than four like we're getting a lot
of games including ABK in here right
this year it's going to be a monster
year it's going to be a monster year I'm
impressed lot of games lot of games
actro par King what's going on back for
dead you see you got your s in the
background lot of games shown what what
impressed you what was your highlights
so yeah the thing I came and looked
forward to the most was I hope they show
a date and we got it for hway 2 so I'm
really excited about that see you
rapping your C you got your sen ready
I'm with you oh yeah and we got our
symbols I was a
huge huge fan of the first game after
trying it out in Game Pass and even for
me personally struggling with mental
health in my past that I was really
excited to see what they were going to
bring out in the second game just the
brutality and the you could see thect
character development going on with her
and just blown away by the graphics in
basically everything that they showed
today beautiful and beyond that I was
yeah definitely Indiana Jones had me
shocked I wasn't expecting to really
think okay this is something I can get
into I thought maybe I'll you know but
then the action they showed and like you
said just disarming everything you can
do with the whip you just get into
personality that you see you get to be
Indiana Jones there where watching the
movie they definitely pull from there
just how the different puzzles that you
get to do how cool that looks and when
he's even just wiping something off of
the surface of like you see the leaves
falling and what happened what you said
oh people are upset because hellblade's
the digital only title oh really no
physical
of it all interesting they did they do
like a promo for it and say like
um really that's interesting I'm
surprised they not do no collector
edition but anyway that's right C
go continue back continue back you say
but yeah just how when he's moving
different things the environment and
opening doors you can see how the
environment reacts to everything he's
doing it's really nice crazy but yeah
and then you got Square Enix coming in
with yeah with the Mana game I thought
that's pretty cool I've tried the one it
out and so yeah that'll be something fun
to check out and if they put uh the RTS
game up for Game
Pass yeah that's just not really my
style no doubt no doubt fan enough adct
man to start with you
bruh how we feeling it was a good event
you know I'm leaning towards like a 7
eight out of 10 okay okay yeah just I
needed more release dates to go higher
than that yeah a that true it was only
one one right only one releas when you
talk about like Indiana Jones 2024 not
even a fall makes me think that's 2025
automatically AOW being fall 2024 that
could easily get pushed to 2025 like I
wanted like more clarification that
these games were coming out this year
and I didn't really get that you know I
do still think that uh Indiana Jones
looks really good I think uh what I
saw is definitely something I would play
uh you know I think they did a a good
job with the what they showed on the
game playay I'm still thinking they
should have gave you the option to play
third person because I know a lot of
people want that and I'm curious to to
see how they and see I machine games
does really good set pieces in first
person so I know yes the game will be
fine but that type of game I feel just
does better in third person but you know
we'll see how it is I think it's still
going to be good I didn't really get to
see much on AOW CU I that's
when I know I got to rewatch it too cuz
I the stream was messing up for me so I
it
was uh like the moment the AOW trailer
showed up that's when king showed up so
I had to like Panic yeah youing you was
working yeah I know I know you was
working the last minute of it of it yeah
I feel so I mean it's good I think it
was a a great show um I am little
disappointed with those release dates
cuz to me like especially Indiana Jones
like this you didn't even put a like a
sector like summer fall like you just
said 2024 they just hit 2024 yeah it
like if you think it's coming out in the
fall why didn't you just put fall and
just you know wrot months or winter to
me that game's not coming out this year
it's coming out next year what game what
game was that so you don't think even
though they put 2024 on you think coming
out you said Indie you don't think ind's
coming out you want you want you got
your knees on there a vow oh
a a vow put
its at least sound like a b knee
challenge coming out so it's just to me
I think they hit it man I'm just trying
trying to KN with you I'm just trying to
find I'm just trying to find knees so we
ain't doing the bend knee so you you
ain't standing on
business that that's that mustard heart
St talking about it call everything
muster hard I don't care like just it
comes down to it's just like you I I
really enjoyed what I saw but I I do
feel like they they they missed the the
expectation I had cuz I was really
thinking these games have been
developing long enough where we're going
to see solid release dates and to me you
show me Indiana Jones it look great but
it's like 2024 you didn't even put
winter or fall like like you you did at
least did that with a vow cuz to me
you have a good expectation that A's
going to hit this year but they just put
2024 on Indiana Jones so that just makes
me think they don't know if it's going
to make it that's what their
expectations are but they don't know can
I can I just Buton can I just button for
a second can I ask a question the panel
question when was the last time they did
a big deep dive into a game and it
didn't come out when they
said I mean usually it's rare usually if
they show it at a showcase
for the most part I mean you have your
your instances once in a while why are
we acting like they're not they just
showed us like an incredible amount show
us they showed us Less on a vow and that
got a fall 2024 did they they they show
guys show a lot of AOW it's just that me
and you ad we missed it we missed it we
were were do show they went in depth on
gameplay they went in depth on traversal
they went in depth on what type type of
the story they we even told us where it
is coronally R ller whatever
that they even showed us where it is
like they
spent like a good amount like 15 minutes
so why why don't you think that they're
gonna why don't you think that they're
going to come out then because they
showed a ton aout had less real estate
in this event and they still put fall
2024 so yeah I don't know I don't know I
mean to me they it don't don't don't
look at me look at them why they put
2024 instead of anything for 2024
everything in this had a a summer fall
but that one they're like we don't in my
eyes in my eyes this might be and maybe
I'm I'm dumb dumb but um this might just
mean that they don't know where they
want to put it yet and they're not going
to put it in front of let's say if it
drops in the fall they're not going to
put it against a vow and another one of
their good games right like I mean maybe
it's just a slot that they don't know if
another studio is going to hit and
they'll put it when they know you know
what I mean you know what I'm start
people in the chat maybe or maybe it's
why because call why is he still talking
n we that we nobody nobody seen that we
hit that so we good The Bu of already
did it the snipers got like no personal
attacks go ahead go feelish [__] about
it I'm good you know clearly I can't get
my opinion on here without the give your
a bet you you stop worry about two
people in in in the chat don't agree
with you that's how
that's what it
is yeah finish finish your say your
thing that's that's it like you know
apparently uh it's a Senda want release
dates these days so that's that's what
you want no it's all good that's your
expectations where what you want it is
what it is let's get to the king where
we at with this direct how we feeling um
first I want to
[Music]
um say uh my heart goes out to uh EV
uh Huff uh he's going through something
really traumatic right now and um he's
watching the show right now from his
hospital bed and uh he hit me up and he
was just had you know super high hopes
and he was depressed yesterday from a
lot of the talk that you know is in the
streets with a lot of these mustard hard
guys you know dudes that don't know how
to hold the line dudes that don't you
know just weirdo stuff and
and Playstation can have a crappy event
and the PlayStation dudes be like it was
a 10 they chest is out they running
through brick walls they smacking babies
they're
like why babies gota get smack they say
yo it's Buck bananas is
nuts
and you get to these Xbox
dudes they could be watching a bomb
show would it be crazy if something else
happens or we need extra sauce or can I
have have more tomatoes on this and
weren't you the one that kept saying
there was a fifth game though a sixth
notice how you notice how I didn't talk
when you was talking but but not I'm
just I'm okay go go for go I just I just
want to go back the person let me be
quiet let me let me sit back and be
quiet you ready let's go okay thank you
all right
so it's just
like I'm watching some of the most
amazing games that Microsoft has put
together all in one show that they said
that's coming out this year right and I
know Game Pass is a problem Game Pass is
a problem as far as placing games
because you don't want to put a game
inside Game Pass that's going to be
cannibalized by another game that's
supposed to be coming out then you got
to look at your contracts or who you got
showing up you know because the square
thing alone is a huge title that you
want to get maximum amount of sales
possible in the summertime you know
window that they gave them and you don't
want nothing to interfere with that
because you want to show excuse me the
metrics that it's viable over here right
not that is you know it's a game pass
but it's in the ecosystem and you want
it to
sell now sen Saga we done seen it enough
I really didn't care to see anymore I
feel you cuz you like I got you know
yeah yeah I'm like okay I got it I heard
your bars already bro I heard your bars
you're dope you're fantastic you spit
nice when is the album released that's
all I needed from you and they they was
like oh May 21st okay oh you locked that
down so this is where you was necessary
for here okay good the real time
strategy guy for the PC game pass stuff
that stuff was everybody was overlooking
it everybody was it was just like they
were just talking about three games they
wasn't even talking about fourth game
and the fact that it did show well and
it did show for realtime strategy type
of individuals that are into that I
would really be down if you gave me a
mouse and a keyboard attachment that I
can sit down and play with and they
really need to start looking into that
because this is the third game that you
have put out that I can't partake in a
way that I want to partake in right so
let's let's get working on that and I
know they're trying to walk away from
making extra peripherals that is only
limited to to a small group but at least
a third party come out with it somebody
you know uh work on this because I
really want to partake on my Xbox where
I want to game y'all say y'all want me
to game where I want to game let me game
where I want to game right
now
boy had a vow let's go M it hit every
box that I had that I was like please
hit this boxes the NPCs look like they
took time with it when they was talking
you know how you got the dead eyes with
some of their games I didn't see that
the language the language was looking
good the the the um the trees the
dialogue trees looked amazing and the
fact excuse me the fact that you can
call a dude a mustard heart and he be
like nah I was there I didn't run and we
got to fight this
out that shows and they told you it's
it's it's a living world the
consequences are immediate not wait
until the end or wait to see if what
ending that you get you disrespect
somebody somebody's Honor on on the line
you going to have to handle the
situation I lik this oh you go to a
scene and somebody got stabbed up and
he's like yo man take my badge
bro
got me yo and his his face was looking
dope then you saw the world the world
was looking dope so everything that
everybody was asking before you just got
a little bit more taste right and I
think they're gonna show the game
probably one more time before they give
a release
date then when my only Enigma was
Indiana Jones I didn't know how to feel
was going with that yeah I was I was
really you know it could have went
really
bad it was the game of the
show it was literally the best game of
the show you make the argument you can
make the argument sto the show yeah
because
graphically that was Harrison Ford yeah
that was that was him that was him young
that was him old they had candy man in
there they they the mice look good the
spiders look good the whip physics it
was like and they all had this look on
their face like we got a secret and
y'all are going to enjoy this 60 frames
per second Graphics looks ridiculous the
the the um the set stages look crazy
when you do certain things you go into
third person the it it had the action
adventure feel of the movies they
captured Indiana Jones and they did it
in a way Microsoft has so many
studios that they're G to find out who's
best suited to do what I'm not fearful
no longer for
blade because that means you went down
the line for who was good for what and
said you guys cuz when I heard machine
games I was like I don't know right I
can't say anything I can't say anything
so this this this right now shows that
they put the proper studio in place to
take care of what they wanted quality
looks fantastic on all the titles we saw
here today the pacing was perfect all
the way through I'mma give the show a
eight because I did I yeah I did want to
have that one more drop that's something
you want six games that because they
they had the they left me they left me
they left me with with the joint they
had the empty space and my my OCD was
kicking kicking you like I was like put
something in there put something in
there pause but The Secret of Mana and
square being stole godam it Ste I'm just
saying we always ask yes for them to
snatch their booze
up they've been snatching their booze up
these last couple of shows like Kimo's
last
show and now this show squid shows up
nobody in this world none of your fake
insiders none of your dudes that was in
anybody DMS not one person said squar
was gonna be there today actually I had
one that was kind of funny but
I you just keep quiet cuz I'm not insid
I just be like oh word you got special
you got special DMS my DMs are different
so and my DMs is hopes and dreams
so the fact of the matter is square
showed up there and said the day that
this releases is the day that it comes
out on your
platform shows the level of commitment
they have with Microsoft that new CEO is
in lock stack with him jacket was hard
body karate everything was great I mean
and and it and they would they they fit
the they didn't look out of place they
that's they they look like they well and
it's a game that's going to get
purchased and it's and I'm pretty sure
it's a game that adct is going to review
adct is going to um uh you know do do
the whole adct you know treatment to it
I know that's G to happen
because not for nothing when is the last
time a square game launched day and date
on the Xbox platform with the other
competing platforms that that's been the
problem right that's the thing that's
been the issue major answer I think
people you know who let me not interrupt
you sorry no just it's just the fact of
the matter
is what more do you Xbox dudes
need like what what more do you need you
sitting there saying oh you need this
and you need that you need this how much
sauce do you need on top of it in
fairness release dates a nice releas no
no release dates is fantastic right
let's get past this first release date
in May if they got to hit I don't want
to hear two weeks before oh we got to
push it back a week I don't want to hear
none of that so you so you rather step
staying on business when it's ready and
you know it's ready then boom so you're
not concerned about fall or summer none
that none that your thing is let them
rock is coming and you you don't care
till you when they ready to show the
they ready show the release but the fact
that it's this year gives you confidence
yeah they say they they they said this
year for all the stuff right right right
this is
January this is the first show
and we know they got more none of the
ABK stuff was there right so they they
really have more and none of their core
Studios fact Xbox game studios none of
them so we didn't get the game pass show
yet it's like it's is is things that are
cooking that they said we got this is
good let's put this out right now and
let's stop all a lot of the conversation
that's out there this is not to make
more
this is to have conversation to give you
strength to boost you to let you know
this year is going to be a damn good
year for you sck around and let's let's
game and I'm not gonna
lie some those four games would be dudes
whole year BR that could be it and we be
most people would be like yo I it agre I
agree I agree can I jump yeah now you
can go ahead it's just for some dude
those four games it's they whole slate
you know you know you had the
PlayStation drop one game last year and
dudes was
satiated that King Final Fantasy 16 do
that voice let's F Final Fantasy 16 but
that's not focus on
the you notice I did not add Square to
the four games I just talked about the
four games so some years this that's and
they said this is the light work this is
our light work they let us know ABK it's
not going to be here year six is still
cooking man wait until the ABK show when
the deal is done complete this I mean
I'm just happy guys and the video is
gonna be Buck
bananas no let me get a couple Super
Chat Liz $5 Super Chat my opinion no one
was expecting Indie a few weeks at the
event no way they put it in this show
and it doesn't come out in
2024 and I think that was the only one I
miss let me just double check I'm sorry
y'all cuz no Sol I got J Rose I got Liz
okay J Boy On The Run $2 Super Chat 10
for 10 I don't care for dates it's Xbox
games um black boxing Kings I love that
what up DMV salute he's just sound like
that's panel that's panel oh that's
what's up up what's up P what's going on
baby yeah yeah so um look man look I I'm
I'm in alignment with a lot of you guys
actually all of you every single point
all of Y I made I do have uh agreement
with with for the most part so look they
what they set it off um with AOW right
AOW was the one who who jumped out first
I believe was unfortunately for me I had
I know adct he's working the technical
thing on the background I'm trying to
help him on on his side and then I'm try
so my experience I'm G have to watch
that over the only thing I'm going to
say I gotta be real y'all know I'm team
upsetting y'all know I the RPG mechanics
are going to be guante the choices are
going to be got I love the biomes my
only thing I'm going be real that I
still need to see I felt the enemy AI
was a little sus on like they weren
reacting like I wanted them to react
right but I then and then I was like is
it just gonna be these little dwarves
dudes or these little dragon face dudes
and then I saw big spiders I saw
whatever whatever I like the the color
patter I like the what I saw from the
environments and I know the story is
going to be but I got to be real now now
this is where gamesy don't get mad I
King excuse me don't get mad because I
know you going hard for the the faces
but it's like after see Indiana faces
and you and blade faces they faces they
it stood out War like oh man it's levels
to with the graphics with the we know
the game gonna be fire yeah but Cog it's
a RPG
ofp I'm just
saying it's levels when it come to the
graphical with the faces with certain
Studio that's all when they to your in
your defense one is an RPG one is
something else
I got you that's all I'm saying I'm
being I'm being difficult on them cuz
that's my baby ien I I totally expected
those faces to look like I like to hear
I like everything else that that was
being done not going at them saying it
looked better than what it did last time
yeah all I'm saying is it's just that
I'm I know why y'all went first yeah you
could not go with them
faces Indiana H blade not no faces out
there like a roller coaster yeah you had
to set it up you had to be like let's
put them on the ferris wheel first yeah
that's smart now the grand the Great
Adventure the big wheel joint up we
going to put them on that last you got
to look at pillars of Eternity and then
that Universe no I get that and some
Grim said it's a good thing it's an art
style I get it I just wouldn't be fair
in that part but I'm not scared of the
game and none of that stuff but the V is
off just Mah I'm with add on that that
right there and um we got what they said
fall for them so they said um yeah fall
2024 for them that's the that's the
second half game and I love that it's
away from hellblade that's time to bre
so I was good with fall I'm like okay
that's the winter Blockbuster you do
your thing over there now for some
people think IND in June I hope I mean
look we gonna get to him um then second
was um who they show second they show
they went right to Hell
blade back for de we in there we we know
what's going on I I don't I am not
concerned the least like I from what I
saw where they going with it I saw a
bigger scope I saw out bright um biome
outside like daytime most of the time we
see very dark it's been very so I'm like
oh maybe they hide and they get to hide
stuff yeah I was like maybe that's the
graphical trick so that they can't hide
backgr oh no no we're outside we're
moving we're doing all of this hell
blade looks phen my thing I thought they
could only do two characters on the
screen on screen I thought they would do
it I I would you k there's a part as
great as hell BL look all this time I
had suspicions that maybe they're doing
tricks just two Bon two people on the
screen oh no no no no they answered
every single one of my question I think
what they're doing in my opinion is
still being secretive with the main
story stuff they saw flash here flash
here flash here flash they don't want to
give you everything but they giving you
enough to show the diversity what's up
how come we a never see that big baby
yeah you see remember the big troll
remember the big troll when she had all
the is on the beach front and the like I
know they got it so what it is they show
you snapshots of each of these different
scenarios over the course of the years
that we've seen this game because in my
opinion they still holding close they
want you to experience it I am not
worried I will say though again it's God
damn it Indiana Jones exposed a lot of
people today because I like oh yeah you
30 now because when I saw Indie weget to
but it's all good looks phenomenal I'm
in there and we got a release she was
outside finally police date yes may top
of the Year Banger very good crazy
loving what I'm seeing from that so yes
and one thing one thing being outside
did you see this game is the first game
that I looked in was like this R is this
Ray tracing cuz that looks crazy it's to
the point where it's like this is this
the the full motion video is this like
or is this and oh that's the gay I it's
to that point where the Synergy of the
graphics is so crazy um shout out to the
liz2 Super Chat any Shadow drop within a
week of e3 showcase maybe we'll see so
we got that then the surprise of the
show you see the Square Enix logo I'm
like okay this is extremely significant
you're getting the brand new IP for all
the hardcore heads that know about The
Secret of Mana and all of that stuff
that is this is humongous their
relationship is bearing fruit
immediately on a new IP so to me me I
have no questions with square eatings
anymore they listen the symbolism of
coming on an Xbox first party show to
come there and say here's our new game
on your Xbox people could take this
anywhere I a GNA I know the the Monopoly
boys don't like this but that could be a
symbol for something too you know you
don't know what why are you here why are
you here this is an exp this is you are
developers
direct people that are on by Xbox y
again this could be Tak I know the
acquisition gang they don't like people
don't like to talk why are you here and
you not in Game Pass so you just showing
up to hey we got a game for you out of
nowhere
listen tell TR you cooking I'm just
saying like we we we have to look at the
sci here anybody who says otherwise has
to at least say okay this is a little
strange to have this big third party
developer on an Xbox first party show
the 360 I feel you I feel I feel you I
feel you I feel you that's he heit you
he 120 and all that sunu all that we
doing all that so that the thing is bro
don't even if this is not your style of
game and you may be a final fantasy guy
stand tight stand tight they that
leather jacket that man had looked like
he's well funded he just looks like he's
he looks like he's in a good space in
his life right now after this other guy
looked like he knew some stuff all right
so there we go we got we got yeah on
facts so then we got we had the amazing
first half boom boom then we get
halftime so you know the strategy game
come out all right half time get your
Refreshments but we know lot lot of
y'all don't like this but look new game
civilization Dev this is going to I
agree with games League wholehearted the
PC Community is going to eat this up and
it is coming to Xbox not like it's that
just the PC only kind of thing no but
wait said PC and okay I'm wrong I'm
wrong my fa let me let me double check
the well that's actually the one thing
PC game pass no no you're right PC it is
PC
says P pass on day one so the PC joint
you know we know the Vibes at this point
for those I'm not condoning it I would
love simultaneous release on all PC
strategy games but we know the porting
process my complain what that is that
controller agree I agree we know what
that is not making excuses for it I
would love simultaneous releases on
strategy games but we've know the
Cadence and we know that they do
eventually come but that's what it is we
know what Market gets at first that's
just what it is I'm not condoning I'm
just telling you what is so that's and
then yeah wait a second what's up RPG R
RPG Guru or whatever Visions a man are
not going to Game Pass it's not so what
no it's launching on it's launching on
Xbox Day One release this was a symbol
this was a symbolic thing this was a
message yeah this is have no business
being
here yeah that this is Xbox first party
what are you here for so people have to
look at the SS of that that's all I'm
saying so okay boom bro I just got to
keep it a bu look and I know there's
going to be some people that's going to
say bro it should have been third person
and that's fine you you could be that
and that's fine but if you going to sit
there and watch what we saw and the 60
frames per second and the animation and
the set pieces and the puzzles and and
the flare and the personality and the
energy of in Indiana Jones and the fact
that yeah of course it is first person
but they are still using some third
person type of mechanics and intro
introducing it in very cinematic
ways bro I was blown away by by indana I
did not expect that to take it and I
think they knew it that's why they saved
it for last and they were popping off
and let me explain something to y'all
I'm with addict machine games bro they
do not miss when it comes to gameplay
when it come to storyline if y'all think
this game going to be I'm telling y'all
right that Todd got his finger all over
it I'm telling y'all right if y' if
y'all don't believe me go play the
morenstein games go play order go play I
they not only is the combat then it's
got the stealth then it's got the
traversal they didn't look like they got
set pieces where they going in the air
and doing this look like the summer
blockbuster movie type joint for the
joint he jumped off a plane onto another
plane C they got they got the hand in
hand if you want to get your one two on
they got listen I'm the guy that was
skeptical of it's first person and I
walked away and Pudgy boy game you can't
say the show got me rock hard with
excitement you can't PA canot say that
you cannot say that but can we buy
Indy's whip broo version it is CRA when
they use the whip as a distraction look
everything I saw completely blown away
and and and the S the fa the facial
details the facial and they there
machine games showed me hellblade of Y
Cool y do what y' do this what we do and
I have to there was levels on certain
things you know saying I have to on
certain things I got to give it to
machine gay like damn optimization
optimization was on just felt butly
smooth and it just silky everything
there was nothing that I was like n I'm
not feeling because every other one you
could pick you say okay maybe H blade
could have been 60 or maybe a v faces
could have this or what AI could have
been them I was like no no no that's
that's that's a complete experience yeah
and the fact that it looks so polished
right now that's the only thing I'll
push back on attic a little bit I am not
worried in like we show so much of it
that I'm like oh I'm not you just trying
to figure out where where you fit in y
do what you I am not worried at and
let's be real In fairness to Xbox we got
to be real nobody even expected this
game to be this year nobody expect even
to see this like people like oh you 2025
the fact all bro like I cannot come at
that's just me I I can understand
anybody saying yo bro I I need more
release that's fair for me you you tell
me about a surprise birthday gift that I
didn't know I was
getting and now I'm worried about what
day the delivery not like I know it's
coming like you told me like I'm there
like I'm good so I'm good um I think
show was an eight out of 10 for me um
fantastic uh uh showcase overall and um
yeah like I said it was it's obviously
some picks with little things here and
there but I just think that their their
their year is going to be tremendous and
and this is this is the set off that's
what I'm talking about this is the set
off this is this bro we didn't even get
to the ex the the summer showcase we
haven't even got to the ABK thing we
even got to the third party like that
that's what's letting you know if
they're coming like like King said if
this is somebody's whole year yep that
we got right now like we have to be
clear like I understand guys's been
suffering for a long time but now 2023
and now 2024 looks even more better so
I'm good that's all I gotta say but I do
got to get going soon but I anybody's
got any oh rating scores on what y'all
gave what was your scores everybody real
quick I forgot adct what was your score
seven out of 10 seven out of 10 adct
King what was your score eight eight out
of 10 back for dead what was your score
I give it an eight okay games League
what was your score oh man uh eight out
of five 8.5 eight out of five eight
8.5 he said eight out of five eight out
of five out of five chat put the scores
in look 8.5 for sure I feel y that's
where I'm at man so look that's all I
got I don't know if y can continue I do
gotta run CU I got to talk to Mr and I
got to do my joint but um yeah man good
show y'all good everybody up in the chat
see the super chats add you gonna close
out or you gonna yall GNA rock on for a
bit adct and I gotta do a live stream
all right cool everybody appreciate
y'all back gamy where can they find you
before we go
I got
you go I got confused
uh who are you and where can we find you
he said I'm still
digesting at gamley um at gamley TKD on
Twitter uh and watch my channel because
we got some I got some interesting stuff
cooking up so you're no doubt we maybe
should put the channel information so we
should know what the channel is but
that's next next time
thenit next time next time you got to be
prepared brother you can't be on
prepared all right but they find out
with the Twitter get them the Twitter
one more time and then maybe they can
find your channel
there well that's why I said at gamley
TKD on Twitter all right there we go
there we go back for de my man that's
did I not say that no you said that but
you a say what the channel but we gonna
let you slide um back for dead what's
going on brother where can they find you
what you got going on yeah I'm just
occasionally I'll be live streaming
games find me up back from the dead ju
on Twitter twitch Rumble YouTube
wherever else and then back from dead
back from dead yeah back from dead one
on Xbox and Playstation nice no doubt no
doubt and then what I want to do real
quick make sure yall go support Lords
gaming.net my man Mar Mo we got the
Roundup article get all the information
in there thank you you just beat me to
The Bu yes you got to put it in there
I'm doing a thousand things man support
Lords g.net shout out my man shout out
to all the Riders we got the all the
announcements from the direct that's up
right there King and adct y' gonna be on
the front line what y'all doing what y
got
playing oh yeah yeah it's Thursday so we
do Boulders gate and we going to take
care of these goblins all right no doubt
no doubt take care of these Goin no
we're going to take care of these
goblins cuz you took care of the Goblins
you did it without me and I'm upset and
I want revenge on these goblins but
listen you can catch me at XO new stuff
is happening tonight um especially
because of stuff happened today and um
all you mustard harded dudes Run for the
hills we're chasing you down you messy
and on that not I'm out of here peace
peace mustard
[Laughter]
Hearts messy you messy let me go y I
gotta M's waiting for me I gotta catch
him all right catch y'all in the minute
you guys gonna go you guys are gonna go
get uh beat by a bear again oh no we
don't stop that pause we get
beat
[Laughter]
send you guys over to uh the stream
we'll be starting here soon all right
adct I'm running to the Xbox okay all
right